يصف بعض الناس ازمه المناخ بالخطر الاكبر
على مستقبل البشريه
[موسيقى]
انقذ الاطفال اكبر حواري مع نحو 55000 طفل
من احدى واربعين دوله بشان قضايا تغيير
المناخ وعدم المساواه لم يبقى من شك بان
خطر التغير المناخي ليس مشكله الغد الاضحى
ازمه الطوارئ عالميه بالنسبه لملايين
الاطفال
فقد ترك الجفاف الذي ضرب كينيا والصومال
واثيوبيا خلال الاعوام الماضيه نحو سبعه
ملايين شخص في امس الحاجه للدعم الغذائي
وارتبطت حالات الجفاف بارتفاع معدلات
التسرب المدرسي التي تتضاعفت ثلاث مرات
وتركت نحو مليونيه طفل بحاجه الى العلاج
من سوء تغذيه الحاد يهدد حياته
لقي اكثر من 1300 شخص حتفهم جراء
الفيضانات غير مسبوقه التي اجتاحت باكستان
ثلثهم من الاطفال
وتسببت هذه الفيضانات في اضرار شديده لحقت
بنحو ثلاثه وثلاثين مليون شخص من بينهم
احد عشر مليون طفل
وبالغ في افغانستان نقصا حاد في الغذاء
بسبب الجفاف والنزاع
غالبا ما يبيت الاطفال جوعها وصلت النسبه
لدى الفتيات ضعفا نسبه لدى الذكور
يظهر تحليل البيانات الذي اجرته منظمه
انقذ الاطفال ان
774 مليون طفل في العالم يعيشون في فقر
متعدد الابعاد معرضين لخطر شديد بسبب تغير
المناخ واظهرت البيانات ان معظمها اولي
الاطفال يعيشون في دول فقيره في جنوب اسيا
وافريقيا جنوب الصحراء
من الاطفال المشاركين في الاستطلاع ان على
الكبار مثل المزيد لمعالجه هذه القضيه
والاستثمار في الاطفال وحقوقهم في الصحه
والتغذيه والتعليم والحمايه من العنف
والفقر ويقولون ان هذا شرط مسبق الوصول
الى عالم اخضر تسوده العداله والانصاف